[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we've all heard of formula one race cars
but how about
formula e this weekend all electric cars
will compete in new york at speeds of up
to 174 miles an hour
it comes after every major car maker
announced plans this year
to go electric several fully by 2035.
some of the technology we're seeing in
the competition could end up in your
neighborhood
errol barnett is at the racetrack in
brooklyn errol good morning
hey there good morning consider this 10
years ago this sport didn't even
exist now what's known as the e pre
boasts 12 teams 24
drivers speeding across at least three
continents this season
and growing it is high energy meets high
tech
and i can tell you that come rain or
shine this weekend these races
are on coming down into the new nouvelle
chicane
de costa to the outside it's a
country-hopping heart-stopping racing
tournament for the 21st century
coming up through beau rivage they're
still three wide electric racing cars
earning fans by burning rubber brilliant
drive from mortara
do you see any other team as your
biggest threat or is everybody a threat
the beauty
of former e is it's so close every team
is a threat
susie wolf is team principal for rocket
venturi racing
fresh off a win in pueblo mexico last
month vaulting her driver edo mottara to
the top
of the driver standings this is one of
our cars getting unpacked the tournament
though
is far from over it's brutal there's
only ever one winner and everybody wants
to win
but sport is also so pure you know
exactly how good you're doing
based on your own track results the
chequered flag falls currently leading
the team standings is mercedes
the electric mobility age is upon us
team principal ian james who worked for
a time at the mercedes plant in
tuscaloosa alabama says what happens
here
can end up in your driveway if you think
about electric mobility there are
certain challenges which come up for the
engineers
ultimately it's how efficient you can
actually make that power unit and the
cars themselves
we can hopefully prove our
competitiveness here that then
translates auto and
also into the road car side of things
what makes formula e racing unique is
that each vehicle is equipped with the
same electric battery and a fixed range
the current version is called gen 2 with
a top speed
of 174 miles per hour how each team
uses that power while conserving energy
makes all the difference
the car from the front to here is the
same for everybody
and from here to the back this is where
they are developing something
fred espinos says teams never reveal
what's under their casings for risk of
exposing
engineering secrets so he showed us
inside a standard race car and showed
what the soon to be released
gen 3 battery will do what will be
different in the new car
is that there will be a second power
trend which will be at the front of the
car
wow and the second power trend will be
there to help the car to go faster at
the start
this temporary race track in brooklyn
feels more like a travelling carnival of
cutting-edge racing technology
the sky's the limit alberto longo
co-founded formula e in 2013 to create a
sport
focused on sustainability we're going to
have
flash charging which is basically going
to be able to charge the car
within the course of 30 seconds but it
does have its fair share of detractors
specifically over the power boost using
fan boost he got to the outside
the game-like concept allows fans to
vote for their favorite driver during a
race
those drivers with the five highest
tallies then get extra acceleration
in a specially marked zone what do you
say to people who say
this feels like a video game you take
that as a compliment or not
i do actually because this is the
intention out of the final corner now
and he is a two times formulary champion
now longo admits his sport does suffer
from a visible lack of diversity he
suggests for every thousand boys there's
maybe a single girl that wants to get
into racing
so motorsports governing body has an
initiative called girls on track
aiming to make all of this all of what
you've seen here more accessible jamie
to young women that's a great idea start
your engine it's going to sound a little
different too errol thank you
you can watch formula e tomorrow at 4 pm
eastern on cbs sports network and sunday
at 1 pm eastern here on cbs
we'll be right back